la pandémie de koffi 19 a
particulièrement touché les personnes
âgées maison de retraite ehpad n'ont pas
été épargnés avec plus de 29 minutes s
est une autre pathologie a été mise en
lumière le syndrome de glissement
habituellement ce syndrome touche 4 % de
la population ou gériatrique hospitalisé
mais pendant le premier conflit non
c'est près de 15 % de ces personnes
âgées qui en ont souffert selon le
docteur lefebvre des noëttes psychiatre
gériatre alors qu'est ce que le syndrome
de glissement est pourquoi at il été
aggravée par la pandémie de covin 19
on y répond dans facture de 5 en
glissement est une évolution négative de
l'état de santé d'un patient
c'est une évolution assez soudaine qui
remarque à part le fait de pouvoir chez
le patient âgé principalement une ont
envie de vivre plus envie de se lever
plus envie de s'habiller de manger de
participer aux activités de communiqué
parfois c'est compliqué envisager aussi
bien pour l'équipe soignante que pour
l'entourage nous avons contacté isabelle
barth
en mars dernier elle raconte son
histoire sur les réseaux sociaux et
décrit le glissement dans son père meurt
cette naine envie de vie elle l'a relevé
chez son père quelques temps seulement
après son arrivée en ehpad
une des caractéristiques du syndrome
sémitisme la vue donc dans un retrait
complet c'est à dire que petit à petit
tout ce qui était encore des motifs de
vie je dirais ont disparu c'est à dire y
lisait beaucoup j'ai arrêté de lire et
regarder les informations à la
télévision il se tenait beaucoup au
courant de l'actualité
c'est devenu pratiquement inexistante
et puis en fait petit à petit il a
refusé de s'alimenter clip s'est mis à
écrire est une façon énorme et il a
refusé de s'alimenter sans l'exprimer
dans son cas a décidé mourir c'est un
suicide pour moi c'est un suicide leur
sillage
difficile de chiffrer réellement le
nombre de personnes âgées qui meurent
chaque année du glissement ce syndrome
est pourtant bien connue des gériatres
et du personnel des ehpad pour gilles
bonnier il peut y avoir deux causes ça
peut être physique ou psychologique
physique c'est suite à une chute
une perte d'autonomie donc ça en train
de chez le patient syndrome de
glissement mais aussi psychologique avec
la perte d'un proche et chez le patient
un geste retrouvé seul sans liens sont
contactés que la famille avec
l'entourage a été particulièrement
difficile et on a résulté quelquefois ce
phénomène de syndrome de glissement le
11 mars 2020 alors que la pandémie sept
ans en france le ministère de la santé
c'est ce pont les visites dans les ehpad
deux semaines plus tard alors que le
pays tout entier est confiné le comité
consultatif national d'éthique alerte
sur le risque de l'isolément pour ces
personnes âgées coupés de leurs familles
dans leur ehpad les en priver de manière
trop brutale pourrait provoquer une
sérieuse altération de leur état de
santé de façon irrémédiable qu'elle même
enlevé est certain le désir de vivre
pendant de longs mois les résidents en
ehpad sont confinés puis un protocole
strict se mettent en place ces mesures
de protection contre le coc u19 ont
alors augmenté le risque de glissements
puisque le lien avec l'extérieur avec
les familles et bouleversé mais de
manière certaine l'augmentation du
syndrome glissement a été important je
pense qu'on a sûrement doubler les
effectifs parce que le lien avec les
familles est essentiel pour la personne
âgée qui chez le patient âgé se
retrouver seul sans lien son contact
avec la famille avec l'entourage a été
particulièrement difficile et on a
résulté quelquefois ce phénomène le
syndrome de glissement pour de
nombreuses familles c'est sûr ce sont
les différents protocoles sanitaires mis
en place pour lutter contre la pandémie
si on fait glisser leurs proches et des
pas mordu covin j'ai été à des premiers
vaccinés les morts à cause du co lead
entre autres un en plus de tout le reste
toutes les conditions étaient réunies
pour qu'une personne qui déjà vive est
extrêmement mal la situation se renferme
complètement et les chip que la vie ne
vaut plus coup d'être vécue dans ces
conditions-là dont parfois des instituts
ou un petit peu déshumanisé même le
personnel soignant au personnel soignant
quand il intervient avec des bouts avec
des masques des vitres en contact
physique est extrêmement délétère pour
le patient âgé pour éviter la
multiplication des cas est l'ismans les
ehpad vont alors proposé de nombreuses
activités et leurs résidents le but
occuper les personnes âgées et les aider
à mieux vivre cette période d'épidémie
plus de présence nos sites où les
paramédicaux la coiffeuse pédicure
manucure
c'est un moment de détente et de lire
extraordinaire avec le patient et on a
demandé aussi au kinésithérapeute d'être
présent tous les jours qui on a
développé aussi l'animation professeur
de musique de chant à quelqu'un qui
faisait de la cuisine des ateliers ç'a
permis évidemment l'éviter syndrome de
glisse plus de présence 13
d'accompagnement cela pourrait être une
solution pour limiter le glissement des
personnes âgées et c'est l'un des
chantiers de la loi grand âge qui
devrait être présenté à l'automne
prochain